YUFENG GUO: If you're
looking for a step by step
walk through of going
from data to preprocessing
to training a machine
learning model and all the way
to deployment in the cloud,
with detailed step by step
explanation, well,
this talk is for you.
With over 500
sessions at Next 2018,
it's totally understandable that
you couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see forecasting
stock returns with TensorFlow,
Cloud ML Engine, and Thomson
Reuters Tick Data in BigQuery,
then stay tuned.
Because here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This session will walk through,
in detail, the queries,
the code, and the
configurations used
to train a model on stock
market tick data sourced
from Thomson Reuters.
Specifically, the
aim of this model
was to predict returns
on a five minute
horizon of market information.
Now, this project
is somewhat special.
And that's because it's really
doing everything in the cloud.
The data is in the cloud.
The preprocessing is
done in the cloud.
And the training of the
machine learning model--
well, it's also
done in the cloud.
This means that even though the
particular model they ended up
using was pretty simple, and
the training data selected
was over a fairly
limited frame, just
five minutes, the solution
that was designed--
it works from the
get go to scale up
to a much bigger data set and a
much more sophisticated model.
Now, concretely, the data
is pulled out of BigQuery
with a couple of
different SQL queries.
And then it's loaded
into a pandas DataFrame.
From there, it's transformed
into TFRecord files.
This is ideal for sending
over to TensorFlow training,
especially if the data were to
then scale up in the future.
There's a great
explanation in the talk
of using feature columns and the
feature spec utility functions
to make constructing an input
function much, much easier.
And, as is often the case, the
simplest part of the process
ended up being the
actual model building.
Now for the training
of this model,
the model was trained
on Cloud ML Engine,
and there is a detailed walk
through of the configuration
file and setup
process that was used,
empowering you to not
only be able to reproduce
this workflow, but
then extend it.
This session was very
much a how to talk.
So if you're ready to dive into
the world of running machine
learning in the cloud, head
on over to the full talk
and get training.
If you liked this video,
give it a thumbs up.
I've included the
link to the full talk
down in the description below.
So be sure to check that out.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great content.
I'll see you on the Next Rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]